كان هناك وقت كان فيه الناس يتجمعون
بأعداد كبيرة من الغرباء على
مقربة شديدة في كثير من الأحيان في الليل أثناء وجودهم على
خشبة المسرح في المسافة
التي كان الموسيقيون يستمتعون بها بدا وكأنه [موسيقى] هذه [موسيقى] [تصفيق] [موسيقى] وكان ذلك كوينزتاون نيوزيلندا  قبل
بضعة أسابيع فقط ، يبدو أنه تمت تغطيته
مجانًا لأن نيوزيلندا
تعني الموسيقى والمرح
واللقاءات ، ومن الملائم أنها منزل مزدحم
يعد بمثابة كنز وطني للكيوي أكثر من
مجرد عمل موسيقي تم
حشدهم
للانضمام إلينا الآن من أوكلاند.  نيل
فين ونيك سيمور ، لذا شكراً جزيلاً لكم يا رفاق
لكونكم معنا ، فنحن
نقدر حقًا
أنه من الرائع أن أكون هنا ، شكرًا لك ، لذا
يبدو أن هناك شيئًا
مميزًا في هذه الجولة ، إنه
يشبه البلد الذي كان نوعًا
ما يستيقظ  من ضباب خفي ،
كيف كان الشعور من المسرح
جيدًا ، كل ليلة قمنا بها في
جولة العرض الـ 12 هذه لنيوزيلندا ، شعرنا
بخصوصية لا تصدق ولا
شيء أكثر من عرض
كوينزتاون  في الواقع ، في أروع مكان
مع الجبال خلفنا ، لكن
الجميع يدركون جيدًا كم
كنا محظوظين لأننا كنا قادرين على التجمع وإقامة
الحفلات الموسيقية ،
وإلمامنا بها وما
فقدناه ، كما تعلم ، كان هناك
شوقًا طوال العام ، لذا
أه حقًا مميزًا وبصيص
أمل
لأه قادر على الاستمرار في
بقية العالم
بالنسبة لنا على أي حال ، نعم بعد حفلة موسيقية واحدة ،
كان لدى New Zealand Herald عنوان منزل مزدحم يعالج
موسيقى البلوز السرية في أوكلاند
بجرعة  من الفرح الخالص وإليك ما كانت
تلك الليلة جزءًا منها هنا
[الموسيقى]
هي
أنت